- Okay. Hi all.
Yinon Costica running
product management, one
of the co-founders at Wiz.
First thank you for coming to
this session and to re:Invent.
Super excited to be here.
And today we're actually gonna cover
how cloud security became AI security
and how are we thinking about securing
the new attack surface that
is now generated with AI.
We have a packed agenda,
I'll try to keep it
in under 45 minutes and leave
Q&A 15 minutes afterwards.
But we're really gonna cover first
how did the attack
surface change as a result
of introducing AI both from the blue side,
from the red side, we're going
to cover AI security with Wiz
and how do we see organizations
customers actually securing
their AI transformation?
We're gonna cover also
how can we accelerate our
security operations, our ability
to detect faster, respond faster,
and be one step ahead
of the bad guys with the
attack surface management
capabilities that we've released
and also how we are introducing agents
to our operating model
to be faster than ever.
So with that packed agenda,
let's start with the
basically how does the
attack surface change
and what are the new things
we should think about
as we think about AI?
And the first thing is really,
does AI actually happen?
Is it a real thing or is it just a hype?
The answer is based on a servers surveys
that we're doing times and again.
AI is real, your development
teams are using it whether you
like it or not, everybody's
adopting it to the scale
that almost every one out,
like just one environment out
of 10 is not using at
least one hosted AI model.
We are seeing that you have AI software
that is hosted on your VMs,
containers also managed AI.
All of the bedrocks of
the world is being used
across 80%, roughly 80%
of all cloud environments.
So it's a real deal.
And even if we look at the more,
let's say advanced AI
implementations, agents, MCP,
these are also in use already
for instance MCP in use
across more than half
of the cloud environments today
or this is one of the fastest
adopted technologies we've
seen historically.
And it's amazing to see
how fast organizations
businesses can actually bring it
into their environments to
make business value out of it.
And from even the
development perspective, 80%
of all environments have at
least one AI ID extension.
And more than this, even when you look
at the GitHub application ecosystem,
almost 20% already run in AI application.
So this is to say that
when we think about AI,
it's not just people experimenting
with like some technologies.
Across the board, AI is being adopted
and it's something that we have to account
for when we think about
our cloud security.
Now, on top of this also the bad guys,
the threat actors are leveraging AI
and we're gonna spend some time
into how should we think about
AI changing the way attackers
are actually behaving?
One thing that is relatively
easy to understand is
that like we are using AI in order
to accelerate, be faster, more efficient
in what we do, attackers
do it in the same way.
So if they want to
create a phishing email,
they can do it faster, better
with AI that's an easy example.
But when we think even about stuff
like weaponizing vulnerabilities,
the time it takes
to weaponize the vulnerability
from the moment the CV
is released to the time you
have an exploit ready can
be automated dramatically with AI.
And we're seeing sometimes
it's down to hours, minutes.
If it's a simple vulnerability
that you can actually
get to a working exploit
that you can start spraying, that's scary.
It doesn't leave us with a
lot of time for patching.
It accelerates in reconnaissance instead
of doing reconnaissance manually,
we can automate it using AI.
So there is a lot of
acceleration that happens
on the red side with AI and in
order to understand basically
that the attack surface is
existing and actually expanding,
we launched recently a competition.
I won't spoil it
because we're gonna run
the competition next week
at Black Europe, but the
competition basically has more
than 20 technologies that
are very commonly used
within AI and cloud native architectures.
Whether these are Kubernetes
technologies, web technologies,
AI technologies like
Ollama NVIDIA toolkit.
And basically we are
asking for researchers
to find RCs on these technologies.
Now I will say that it's
gonna be very interesting
to see the results.
We've received a numerous
basically candidates for RCs.
But the more interesting
thing, and it's really
to understand that the vulnerabilities
that are found are not only
found in the components
that we're using to
build our AI applications
and cloud application.
They're actually found
through AI research.
So AI is helping this time, the good guys,
but in other cases also the bad guys
to find vulnerabilities in any software
that we're using faster.
So that's just to think
about accelerating processes.
And one of the other
things that we've seen
with AI, an emerging use of AI in malware.
Now this is like relatively novel.
You can see example, the first example
I think was in LameHug.
It was reported by the Ukrainian cert
and this is basically a
malware that got commands
through and basically ran it as a prompt.
So you can literally read the comments
that the malware received.
It's like plain English,
make a list of everything
that you see, search for secrets, search
for a sensitive file, search for access
to production environment.
And also in the Amazon queue
basically developer extension
attack that happened, it was
also leveraged AI prompts
on the device itself.
The most recent example for it were came
in the singularity attack were basically
through a supply chain vulnerability
threat actors were able
to land on developer machines
and then you can see the
type of prompts they ran
on top of it, a search
for sensitive file, search
for secrets that will gain them access
to production environments to code.
And this is just, and by the
way, everything I'm saying
is just the tip of the iceberg.
We have fantastic
research that is published
on our blog and you can
really read through.
This is like yet another
research paper by Scott Piper.
It really shows how malware
is transitioning to simplify.
So if you are running locally,
your agent malware can use it as well.
And our IoCs that used to
be IPs hashes now become
basically sentences in English
that has a malicious
intent, right? (chuckles)
So that's what we start thinking
when we think about a new
attack surface,
not just accelerating things
we're already familiar with.
So new techniques, we have
what we call living off the LLM.
I get to a machine, then it has agents
I can leverage these agents to pull
to basically move laterally
to pull to do reconnaissance.
So that's one example.
Second one is using AI related
components, models, prompts,
MCPs compromise them,
having a malicious model on hugging face.
So if someone downloads it
and uses it, it infects an environment.
And lastly, agent compromise.
We have seen again recently
the sales SalesLoft
drift attack where through
the code of the agent,
basically the threat actors
were able to get keys tokens
to sensitive customer environments.
And this is just to show
that the attack surface now
is not only accelerating
because of the use of AI,
it's actually expanding.
Vibe-coding is another great tool
that is being used more and more.
It's great, it allows non-developers
to develop applications.
It allows developers to develop faster.
But one of the things we've seen,
and that's again a series of
research papers we've released,
is that vibe-coding
platforms have some patterns
in which they produce the code.
And some of these patterns
are vulnerable by design.
For instance, you implement authentication
and the entire logic sits on
the customer on the client-side
or you embed secrets or tokens
and then they are downloaded
to the client-side as well.
And we're seeing these patterns.
There are known vulnerabilities,
but this time it's actually the platform
that generates it systemically
into the applications.
So we think about vibe-coding
and this is again introduces
a whole new area of risk.
For instance, are the
vibe-coding platforms generate
secure code or maybe they have
some systemic risk we have
to account for.
Like any other application,
we generate an application,
there may very well be
vulnerabilities in it that we need
to fix non-systemic endemic
to the application we created.
And the last piece, attackers
can vibe-code as well.
So in the past to be an
attacker and develop attacking
and like attack tools, offensive
tools, it required a lot
of efforts and usually they were generic
and not very specific.
But if it's very easy to develop tools,
maybe I can develop a
tool per target, right?
So I can become very targeted
in how I develop vibe-code offensive tools
so I can get faster during attacks.
So all of this we try to
map and understand all
of these new risks and
how should we be thinking
about these new threats.
And we came up with this quadrant model
and I'm gonna spend a bit of time on it
because I think it's
important to understand
that a lot of the things
we see are actually related
to an attack surface we already know.
Code secrets, these are things that were
in using attacks and will be used.
But obviously threat actors
can use existing techniques
or new techniques to
exploit it faster, better.
The other thing that we're seeing
is a completely novel attack surface.
Like the models like we now
we have training data sets,
but let's say training
data sets in public buckets
that are now exposed.
This is an existing technique targeting
a new attack surface.
So the other dimension that we want
to think about is whether
it's a new technique
or an existing technique?
Are the threat actors
using the same things
or are they inventing
more stuff, new stuff
that we need to account for?
So when we think about the new
stuff we want to account for,
so the AI powered malware is
definitely a new technique
but it uses existing attack surface.
And if you think about
these four quadrants,
this actually gives us a
really good understanding
on how should we think about our response
to these attacks, to this new
expanding threat landscape.
First on the that are known techniques
with expanded attack surface, we need
to be really good in keeping up
and improving the platform we use
to secure the to create code.
We need also to secure the code.
We need to think about
every single code piece
of code we generate
and how do we secure it
at the get-go, even if it was vibe-coded.
On the flip side, if we look
at the new components, we
have to extend our tooling
into securing the new
attack surface as well.
So when we think about okay,
how do we secure AI applications?
We have to extend our CSPMs, our Synapse
to do AI-SPM.
We want to protect AI as well.
Same concept extended
to a new attack surface.
On the novel techniques,
this is really tricky.
How can we face all of
these novel techniques
that are now being applied against us?
So one on the existing attack
surface always keeping great
fundamentals is key.
We have to scan better, we
have to be faster, we have
to implement fundamental security first.
But then we also need to start thinking
how can we leverage in our
defenses AI based tools?
So they AI based tools will test us,
will tell us whether we
are doing a good job.
So when we are actually
scanning our environments,
we'll do it with a new
AI enabled, let's say
view like the threat actors use.
And then on the bottom
right quadrant, that's
where we are gonna see
a lot more innovation
because these are really new threats.
So malicious models, we had
to come up with a concept
to how do we scan models?
How do we actually do it the same way
that we scan containers
but we needed to build it
from scratch, we needed
to make it available.
And same thing will happen across all
of these new techniques
on the new attack surface.
That's where we are going
to continue and innovate.
But the good news is that
the other three quadrant,
we can actually secure it today.
And we can work on it
and we can actually
fortify our AI applications
with the tools we already have.
The last challenge is really
about the visibility piece.
And when we think about AI visibility,
it's such a hard problem
and I want to spend
like a couple of minutes
explaining like why is it so hard?
Answering a very simple question like
where am I using AI in the environment?
So first what is an AI application, right?
So you have the
infrastructure, the transit.
When we think about the
infrastructure, you have containers,
you have gateways, you
have buckets, databases,
these are the things you consume from AWS,
other cloud providers on any application.
So that's a Synapse layer,
right? The infrastructure.
Second, you have the new
components, the model, the AI.
You have the model, the training
pipeline you have basically
where actually you're storing
the data for the pipeline.
You have the guardrails,
you have the prompts, you have the MCPs,
these are the new
technologies you're bringing
into making this is what
makes it an AI application.
And then you have the
data component to it.
Data is important from
three different angles.
One, what is the data that is
the input from the outside?
So what data comes and
leaves to the end user?
What data was the model trained on?
And then what data does
the agent have access to?
Because I can trigger an agent to go
and pull new data, I need to be able
to know what it is accessible to?
So this is the third layer of AI.
And then the last layer is
actually the application itself.
Where does the code see
how is it exposed, how is it configured?
And then only when you combine all
of these four components together,
this is where you're able
to say, okay, I understand
that I have an AI application,
this is how it works
and these are all the
components that pertain to it.
Because as a threat actor, I
can go with every single layer
and try to compromise your AI application.
And why is it such a hard task?
Because do you know what other
tool has visibility to all
of these layers in one piece?
That's why when we look at the Synapse,
the Wiz graph security graph,
we feel like we have a
really good understanding
of where the AI applications live,
how are they constructed,
where are they running?
And just to make it a bit
more complex, (chuckles)
it's actually a lot more complex
because I showed you
a naive example on AI.
But if you think about the decisions,
the architectural decisions
that developers can make in
building these application.
So they can take the model,
they can host it locally
on a VM, on a container,
they can use it as a pass
from Bedrock, they can use it
as a SaaS from open AI.
They can actually, they
have multiple choices
and we as security we need
to account for all of them.
When we think about agents, same thing.
When we think about identities,
how do agents actually can perform tasks?
They can get cloud roles, they
can have applicative roles
and they can have SaaS roles.
We need to account for all
of these choices. (chuckles)
So not to make it too complex,
but we have a very hard problem
actually understanding all
of the AI applications that
live in our environment
so we can start securing them.
And we spent a 15 minutes
like covering around
what is the impact on our attack surface?
What is the impact that
on both blue side red side
that we should account for?
And just to summarize this,
we we think about four items mainly
a new technology stick
that we need to secure.
A new construct like agents
that are operating in our environment
and then acceleration of two processes.
Acceleration of development, so more stuff
to secure and acceleration
of threat to actors
and how they can weaponize
and carry attacks against us.
And there now to the silver lining,
we have the tools to secure.
Okay, so let's look at it in a, sorry,
let's look at it in two ways.
One, how do we extend the tooling we have
to secure AI workloads?
And second, how do we leverage
AI to become better, faster
in what we do so we can be faster
than the threat actors using AI?
So let's look at AI security.
We're gonna do it in three sections.
The first section is how
do we use a Wiz Synapse
to secure AI workloads?
Second, how do we use an automated tooling
like an attack surface
management capability
to identify exposures we need to fix
before others can find them?
And third, how do we implement agents
into our operating model
so we become faster?
So tackling the AI security challenge.
First we need to tackle shadow AI.
If we don't see it, we cannot secure it.
It's true, always true.
So the ability to really
map all of the components
of the AI are, it's really the key
to start an AI security program.
The second thing is mapping
all of the infrastructure risks
that we are already familiar with.
If we know how to secure buckets
from being publicly exposed,
let's protect our training data sets
so they won't be exposed
on public buckets.
And mapping it that way will allow us
to actually use existing
scanners, existing processes
to secure our AI applications
from the infrastructure today.
And this is where we're
actually seeing most
of the AI related AI applications related
breaches actually come from
the infrastructure layer,
not from the application layer.
So this is like the
first step that is key,
second step that is key.
And then we can layer on top all
of the AI native risks, AI native risks.
Like how can we secure the models we use?
How can we assure the guardrails.
And last, monitoring the actual activity
on the AI application.
There is a lot that we can do
by monitoring AI, monitoring models.
Whether it's model
escape, malicious behavior
of an agent and so on.
And then we can monitor it live
and detect threats as they happen.
But there is a lot more we can do
before that to prevent
the threat initially.
So let's start with visibility.
We start with connecting to
all of your cloud environments
to connecting to your SaaS environments
and connecting to your code.
This is allowing us across all
of the development lifecycle
to detect the full breadth of AI
that is in use in your development teams,
in your production environments today.
Whether it's identifying SDKs in the code,
whether it's identifying past services,
bedrocks used in your cloud, whether it's
to identify training data sets in buckets.
More than this, today we have
the service catalog capability.
The service catalog actually
takes all of these components,
builds them in a service catalog view.
So you have an applicative
aggregation of these resources,
every single service and
all the resources it uses.
And then you can have a very simple filter
called does it have AI? (chuckles)
And you can go to the service catalog,
it's automatically generated,
scans your environment
and then you can filter
what are all the services
that have an AI component to them?
And that's a denominator you're gonna use
across your AI security
journey, this is a foundation.
And if I am asking you today,
let's say you're a CEO comes
to you today and asks you,
okay, give me the full list
of all the AI applications
in our environment today?
Are we able to give an answer?
Not so much, but through the
service catalog we start having
a structure where we can actually identify
and have governance around
everything that is AI.
And when we think about AI,
so building this inventory will allow us
to build a program will also
allow us to remove shadow AI.
And I think the most prominent
example for shadow AI,
when deeps was announced almost 10%
of all cloud environments were using it
within a week, within a week.
And we were asking ourselves
and with our customers,
how can we help customers
really identify all
of these new technologies
and remove them from the environment
if they're not approved?
And that's why we have invested
in these capabilities
to create visibility.
So you can see the SDKs in the code,
you can see the models in your cloud
and then you can put
guardrails around what's
to use and what not to be used.
The lesson very important point
is when we think about AI,
it's not only the application
itself, it's also all
of the pipeline that led to the model.
So we want to know which data
training data sets were used
in order to train a model.
So the visibility doesn't go
only to the app, it's actually
to the entire lives
and the entire pipeline
that created the model for instance.
Second, we take all of
the scanners that we have.
And we have scanners for
identities to identify
what are the permissions
that are granted to agents?
We have scanners on vulnerabilities
so we can scan models
and AI technologies SDKs
to see that there are not vulnerable.
We can scan network access
to see which ones are internet facing.
And we layer everything
into the same graph
and we are also extending
it with new scanners,
for instance, scanning models for malware,
for malicious behavior.
So we start scanning everything that we do
and we layer it into using
the same vulnerability scanner
that use configuration.
We have released dozens
of different configuration posture rules
that extend the CSPM to AI resources
like bedrock and SageMaker.
So you can configure your
cloud resources as you should.
So when you're looking at
your existing scanners,
you should really make sure
that they apply seamlessly
to your AI workloads, to
your expanded attack surface.
And we have done it, so out
of the box you don't need
to click anything for it, it just works.
So we scan your entire environment
and we map it to the vulnerabilities,
misconfigurations, exposures,
lateral movement path
of identities that are attached to agents
and also to the new scanners
that we have launched.
One challenge is really how do we account
for the new platforms that
are generating applications?
And one of our partners
Lovable, in this case, it's one
of the fastest growing
vibe-coding platform
and really we did a lot
of research with them
on vibe-coding security
and what need to be done.
One of the things we
have just implemented is
that any mutual customer
can now basically see
with scans available in their
lovable portal, they can scan.
The scan will be based on the
same policies you're using
for your code security today.
So you don't like, you have the same set
of policies applied across
vibe-coded applications
and traditionally developed applications.
And then you can see the
findings of the code both in Wiz
but also in by the developers in Lovable.
So we can start in injecting
the security mining mindset
into the developed application
even if it's vibe-coded.
So we standardized across
vibe-coding, traditional coding
and it's not such a scary thing anymore
because we have our
security guardrails applied.
So that's a new integration that happens.
And when we think about how
do we prioritize all of this?
Because like any scanner,
this will produce
many misconfigurations,
vulnerabilities, exposures.
But we really want to know
what do we need to focus on?
And this is where the graph plays
as always a significant role.
We actually layer everything
into the architecture we
have built in the graph.
We try to map these attack path.
We try to find whether we have risk
to the AI pipeline or
through the AI applications.
And the examples are
just surfacing from with
through the graph detections
we have for instance.
And these are all based on real examples.
Externally facing MCP that
has access to a cloud role.
The cloud role has excessive
access to data they shouldn't.
Someone can literally ask the MCP
to get data and the tooling will do it.
You want to avoid exactly these type
of exposures and you can
do it using the graph.
We can actually see
from the exposed element
to the application, to the identity,
to the actual sensitive
data that it can access.
Same thing about exposing
applications that have agents
that have access to sensitive data
and they all surface regardless
of the platform, regardless
of the implementation
through the security graph.
So you can prioritize it
to your development teams.
And these are all things
that happen today,
like it's not roadmap and these are things
that you connect with and
you can start prioritizing
these combinations across
your AI applications.
Last but definitely not least,
the ability to monitor
the behavior of the AI
and be able to detect whether you have
actual malicious activity
carried against it.
So for instance,
detecting malicious models
or compromise models or model escape.
So this ability is actually achieved
by monitoring the environment
on which the model runs
typically like hosts.
And we have the runtime sensor
that is now able to monitor
models and detect this.
We should also look at the control plane
and identify let's say abnormal activity
around your LLM resources.
So we can identify LLM hijacking attacks
that we see also in the world.
And these are all components
that are related to
our defend capabilities
that is really about monitoring
your cloud environments, your runtime,
your runtime workloads
and detecting when bad things happen
so you can respond timely and contain.
So summarizing AI security
in just a few steps.
First, AI visibility first and foremost,
that's a foundation for your
entire AI security program.
Second, scanning for AI risks,
whether these are the known
risks, vulnerabilities,
misconfiguration, whether
these are new risks,
then we prioritize, we remediate
the things that matter.
There is a term coined
by Simon Willison that
is called the Trifecta.
Trifecta means that you can have input
to an application with
access to sensitive data
and it can respond back
with a sensitive data.
So we want to basically be
able to block these type
of toxic combinations, right?
And this is what we do by
prioritizing the issues in Wiz
and last having the runtime monitoring
on a every AI workload
so we can detect threats.
This was AI security
101, you can do it today
with your Wiz environment.
And second,
this is a new capability
we have just GAD this week
and this is the attack
surface management capability.
I'm super excited about this capability.
It's very different
than how typical attack surface
management tools operate
because it is tightly coupled
with our security graph.
And I want to try to explain
why is it so dramatic in terms
of how we think about
attack surface management
to couple the external scanning
with the deep understanding
of the cloud architecture, the
graphs, the security risks.
First, when Wiz connects
to an environment,
the first thing we do is
actually analyzing really good
what are all the potential
exposures this environment is.
Whether it's a checkbox somebody did,
the make this serverless function public,
make this bucket public.
And whether these are applications
that you're exposed through
gateways, load balancers
and so on Wiz maps, all of
this we make public repos
and you can actually have
a really good understanding
of what's potentially exposed.
Through the attack surface
management capability,
we are now automatically scanning them
from the outside like a
threat actor would do.
And we're able to test first fingerprint
what is the technology that is exposed?
Is it a database of this type?
Is it a Jenkins, is it
what is the technology?
And then we are able to test
for multiple different risks
threats against it live.
So if we get a qualified validation.
Did you open in this
case like a PostgreSQL
with the default admin credentials?
Did you have a Jenkins
with misconfiguration
that allows access to configuration files?
Did you expose a resource
with a vulnerability
that can be exploited?
We're doing these simple
checks from the outside
and we are able to validate these risks,
but that's only the first step.
Typically with a attack
surface management tools,
you get the external finding
and now it's up to you
to go try to triage it, find
who owns this resource,
where is it running?
Maybe it's in the cloud so
it's ephemeral, so it's gone.
And so who does own it?
And then you have many questions
on the triage that actually prevents us
from automating the response to it.
But not with Wiz.
With Wiz we have the entire
story behind under the cover
so we know which resource
actually exposed this endpoint.
We know who like what
can it actually access
so we know whether it's
a sandbox environment
or maybe the main way to your crown jewels
in your crown jewel database.
And then we're able to create
an impact analysis saying this
externally facing asset
has validated exposure
and also a validated impact.
So we can prioritize better
but more than this we
created the attack with,
but we also know who owns it.
Through our code analysis we can correlate
the cloud resource with
the code contributors
and now we have an understanding
of who owns a resource, who can fix it.
And we can start automating the response
in terms of ticketing PRs in order to get
to the fastest resolution possible.
Because we know this is a ticking bomb.
We know that if we were able
to find this, the threat actors can.
And the goal here is actually
to create SOC level findings
for risks before it becomes an incident.
And this is how powerful this tool is.
But one thing is even more powerful.
In order to enable it, it's a toggle.
There is zero deployment,
there is nothing.
You basically have a
toggle and you're done.
It's going to scan your environment
and going to surface the
attack surface findings
that matter so it can be covered today.
So that's a very powerful way to get ahead
of the attackers and become faster
in how we identify these
potential exposures
and respond to them timely.
And the third pillar that I want
to cover is how do we use
agents in our environment,
in our security operations
in order to be faster?
And for years since the day one
at Wiz, we always talked about
the cloud operating model.
The tools, the technology is great,
but the real thing that
matters is are we able
to change the way we
are operating in order
to really solve the
challenge of cloud security?
And we always talked about democratization
because if we were able to
find the things that matter
and democratize them
to the development team
so the development teams
can fix them immediately,
we are actually fixing
the biggest bottleneck
we had in security.
So now the entire development community
in our organization is working with us
to secure our applications,
so that was great.
It allowed us also to shift
left with preventive security.
So once you have a developer,
not like a development team
that sees how how good looks like,
but also how bad looks like,
they're much more inclined
to then implement guardrails
into their development processes
in order to prevent mistakes, risks
from being introduced in the first place.
And that's how we were
able to introduce Wiz Code
and actually shift all of the policies
to the development experience
itself to the SDLC.
So we are fixing it at
the source when it's easy
to fix and not afterwards.
And last, after we have
cleaned up the environment,
we have better processes
to deploy, to remediate,
then it's a perfect time
to bring in the SecOps.
They can actually monitor the
environment, they can respond
to threats in the cloud environment
and they can grow their
proficiency in what does it mean
to really address, contain
threats in cloud setups.
So this was the operating
model we've started,
but the core of it, the
foundation was always the graph.
The graph is a thing that
allowed us to prioritize.
It's allowed us to explain visually.
You don't need to understand much
about this implementation
on this implementation.
When you see an attack path, you see it.
You're saying okay, I need to fix it.
Whether you're in SOC, whether you're
in the development team,
whether you're in security, you get it.
But more than just humans,
what we actually figured out
that if we can teach our agents
to understand the graph,
ask questions on the graph.
They can actually become
very, very powerful as well.
They can be become our colleagues, right?
They can ask questions on the
graph, they can get answers
and that's what we've been
doing in the past year.
So any agent is as good
as a model behind it.
And what's a better way to model security
and cloud than the Wiz security graph?
So the first thing that we've done,
and this is something maybe I should ask,
how many of you're running like MCP
with MCP today implementing
your own agents
with the show of hand?
Not too many. Okay, this is
something you can do today.
There are fantastic examples with Wiz.
So let's walk through the,
let's say history of applications.
We used to build applications
and we wanted to integrate.
So we said okay, it has to be API first.
We did it API first.
And now the next wave is
you have to be MCP first.
You have to make everything available
through an external MCP server.
So if you have a team that wants
to know something once context
from Wiz, they can just ask
and they get it in
their native experience.
And that's exactly
what the Wiz external MCP
server allow you to do.
It allows you to streamline
the context from Wiz
to any team, any persona you need.
And we have fantastic customers
that were really sharing how they did it.
We have an example with Grammarly,
again, it's public, you
can go on the website.
Basically Grammarly integrated
into their SOC through the MCP server
of Wiz context about cloud resources.
They were able to achieve 90% efficiency.
90% reduction in time it takes
to the SOC analyst to respond
to threats in cloud given the
context they got from Wiz.
So it's really powerful
and it's achievable today.
So the first thing we would say
in terms of extending
Wiz to agencies, use MCP
to bring context, bring
the knowledge from Wiz
to any persona, any team that needs it.
And you should ask it from
any other vendor, right?
It's not only from Wiz,
you can correlate it
with your threat intelligence agent
with your C agent, with
your ticketing system.
So everything becomes part
of your custom agents.
And this is very achievable today.
Second thing that we've
launched is the SecOps agent.
Now when you are a SOC
analyst, you get a threat,
you start investigating
it, you make queries
in the portal, you use a graph to look
for dependencies, relationships
and over the year we've
basically templatized what,
how does a cloud threat
investigation process look like?
And we were able to
create this knowledge base
that says if you see this,
then you need to look
at all of the these aspects.
And we've done two things.
We taught the the agent
how to query on the graph,
but we also created on top of all
of our APIs tools so
the agent can use them.
So it can read issues, it
can read vulnerabilities,
it can read all events, it
can read all of the context
that a human analyst,
SOC analyst would read
in the Wiz portal.
And now the thing we did
is just every single threat
that is triggered in Wiz Defend
is automatically investigated
by the Wiz SecOps agent.
And we can provide the
full investigation summary,
but it's not just an investigation summary
that is black boxed.
It's actually using the same data
that the SOC analyst can use.
So it has a hundred
percent explainability.
You can drill down to every
single investigation step SQAI.
It helps in both ways.
We help analysts to understand
what are best practices
to investigate threats in cloud?
But on the other hand we can
actually gain more inputs
about we need to also to investigate this,
we need to investigate that.
So it allows us to learn as a team.
And lastly it provides a verdict.
Based on this investigation, I was able
to see that this is a common pattern.
That's why last time you ignored it.
So I suggest we ignore it as well.
We can do it automatically.
We provide like the real severity
or maybe it looks like a medium,
but it's weird enough
in order to trigger it
as a critical, so it is
able to provide a verdict.
Is it malicious? Is it benign?
Is it an automated test? And
what's the true severity?
We should think we should provide it.
And that way your SOC analyst, instead
of focusing on five alerts a
day, they can actually do 50.
And this is really when we get a scale
and we're able to do not
only addressing the threats
that we see today, we're
now able to do much more
to see much more through the mediums,
through the things we rarely see.
We can do more hunting.
So we have a lot more
opportunity to extend the horizon
than just dealing with false negatives.
Right? And then the third
pillar is a remediation agent.
The remediation agent is key
in order to understand
how to fix an issue.
Today when we trigger an
issue, you see the attack path
and typically you go to
the development teams
and they know well we
shouldn't touch here.
Maybe we should fix
there, this is not in use.
Maybe we can just, you know,
shut down the public exposure.
Maybe we can trim the
right size, the permissions
because it's not needed.
It's a lot of knowledge that
is not written anywhere.
The development teams know it
because they know it, right?
They know their application.
But we have the knowledge
and we can sequence these questions
for our remediation agent
to basically see whether a
public exposure is actually
in use or not, whether
permissions are in use or not.
Whether a resource can be
remediated without impact
on the environment, whether
there are dependencies or not.
Whether this bucket is
click oped from the portal.
So you can do the fix
directly in the CSP portal
or whether this bucket
is actually a result
of a cloud formation or a Terraform file.
And you should apply the fix in the code
and we know who is a developer
and we can actually create the PR.
So basically the remediation
agent is analyzing the
ownership, what is the impact
analysis, the attack path,
and what's the best course of action
to remediate a certain issue
that is identified by Wiz?
So MCP, the SecOps agent
and the remediation
agent are all available
for you to integrate today
and accelerate dramatically your
cloud operating model using
these agentic capabilities.
And I know I covered
a few different areas,
but it really comes down to
the model we discussed earlier.
How can we extend the
Synapse to secure any type
of AI workload that is now
created in our environment?
How are we able to
accelerate the detection
of exposures threats
before automated attackers
would do it using ASM?
And third, how are we able
to accelerate remediation
response using agents within Wiz?
And these are all the capabilities
that were launched actually
recently you can use today
that feed exactly into this
winning AI with AI model
where yes, there are new
challenges that are introduced,
but yes, the tooling we have today,
the processes we have implemented
for cloud security are robust
enough in order to accelerate,
in order to support this
new technology stack
that is introduced, these new challenges.
And we're confident that as
we continue to implement,
we will be able to securely
enable AI for your businesses,
for your developers.
And with that, this was
a tip of the iceberg
in terms of what Wiz can do.
We will be super excited to show you
like a full demo answer any
questions in our booth, 1447
and just reminding Wiz is a
platform, we covered a lot
of the capabilities.
Wiz Code secures the code.
Wiz Cloud analyzes your cloud.
Wiz Defend is for SecOps
team monitoring, responding
to threats, so a lot to show there.
We are a platform to actually secure
the entire cloud development lifecycle.
And with that, I really want
to thank you for the session.
I'll be here for any
questions you may have or
in the booth and thank you very much.
Enjoy re:Invent.
(audience clapping)